According to the ICH GCP guidelines, there
three key roles in the clinical trial process.
The ethics committee representing
the regulatory authority,
the sponsor initiating and financing the project,
and the investigator conducts the research.
Investigator
The ICH-GCP defines the investigator as "a person
responsible for the conduct of the clinical trial
site. If a trial is conducted by a team of
individuals at a trial site, the investigator
is the responsible leader of the team and
may be called the principal investigator."
Co-investigator is a term that pre-dates the
ICH-GCP. It has subsequently been replaced
by the term sub-investigator. The ICH-GCP
defines sub-investigator as any individual
member of the clinical trial designated and
supervised by the investigator at a trial site
to perform critical trial-related procedures
or make important trial-related decisions.
These may include associates,
residents or research fellows.
In a clinical trial, the responsibilities
of an investigator generally include:
1. Protecting the rights, safety and
welfare of subjects in the clinical study
2. Ensuring that informed consent is properly
obtained from clinical trial subjects
3. Conducting the clinical study and directly
overseeing the administration of the test
products to the subject. In situations
where there is a team of researchers,
the investigator will act as the team leader
4. Ensuring that the clinical trial is
conducted in accordance with the signed
agreement and the investigational plan
5. Controlling the products under
investigation including supervising
medical-device use and disposal
6. Ensuring proper record-keeping
and reporting requirements are met,
for example, mandatory safety reporting
Sponsor
In the conduct of a clinical trial,
a sponsor is an individual, institution, company
or organization that takes the responsibility to
initiate, manage or finance the clinical trial,
but does not actually conduct the investigation.
The specific requirements for a
clinical study sponsor can vary.
Generally, a sponsor is responsible for:
1. Selecting the investigators
2. Providing investigators with the necessary
information to conduct the clinical trial
3. Ensuring proper monitoring
of the clinical study
4. Ensuring all the necessary
ethic reviews and approvals are obtained
5. Preparing and submitting clinical
trial applications and amendments
to the appropriate regulatory agencies
6. Ensuring that any reviewing ethics board
and regulatory agencies are promptly informed
of any significant new information, for example,
important findings that affect product safety
7. Ensuring compliance with labelling,
reporting and record-keeping requirements
8. Refraining from engaging in promotional
activities and other prohibited activities such as
commercializing an investigational medical device
9. Ensuring that the clinical study is conducted
in accordance with Good Clinical Practice
Sponsor-Investigator
A sponsor-investigator, on the other hand, takes
on the responsibility as a clinical study sponsor
and also conducts or oversees the clinical
trial. Thus, a sponsor-investigator must comply
with the applicable regulatory requirements that
pertain to both the sponsor and the investigator.
Sponsor-investigators also generally
need to manage the following:
1. Securing funding for the clinical trial
2. Applying for the appropriate insurance
3. Generating the appropriate clinical trial
documentation (for example, informed consent,
protocols) and submissions (for example,
ethics and/or regulatory submissions)
4. Ensuring adequate resources are available
for the duration of the trial (for example,
experienced staff, investigational and
control products, clinical and medical
supplies, an analytical laboratory)
5. Creating appropriate written
procedures (for example, standard
operating procedures related to GCP)
6. Meeting all the applicable regulatory
requirements such as obtaining and maintaining
necessary approvals from the relevant
ethics review boards and regulatory agencies
Summary
In summary, the management of sponsor and
investigator relationship is of central importance
for planning and executing clinical trials.